JJ BEHRENS: Howdy.
I'm JJ Behrens and this
is Jarek Wilkiewicz.
And in the Google Hangout
is Jeffrey Posnick.
And we're here to have our
next episode of YouTube
Developers Live.
How you guys doing?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Doing good.
How are you?
JJ BEHRENS: Awesome.
So Jarek, I was watching the
videos of our talks at Google
I/O, and I noticed that during
the gaming talk, you were
actually responding to
email while there was
someone else speaking.
I mean, I've joked about your
connectivity before, but
that's pretty incredible.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yes,
I think I am
working on my email addiction.
I think I have made some
progress on my vacation as we
discussed last time.
I was off the grid for
about five days.
JJ BEHRENS: Did it hurt?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I had severe
headaches and withdrawal
symptoms, so my effort
has failed.
But I am trying to improve.
For that particular session,
which we'll cover in more
detail later on today, we're
actually working through
uploading demos, and I was
checking to see if actually
the demo has uploaded.
So it wasn't email, per se.
I was checking the
YouTube out.
JJ BEHRENS: OK.
No, no, no.
That's to be expected.
That's just who you are.
I've mentioned this
multiple times.
So another surprise secret
hidden guest that we have
today is Amanda Surya,
our boss.
And last week, we had a meeting
with all the people in
Google Developers Live and we
decided that the shows would
be a lot more interesting if
for every show, the boss of
the people involved in the show
would come and make faces
just to liven up
the atmosphere.
So if I start laughing,
yeah, that's why.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: We have live
audience, online and offline.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, just
kind of strange.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
No pressure, JJ.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah,
I don't know.
So today, we're going
to do an I/O recap.
So we'll talk about all the
things we talked about at I/O,
which you could watch,
after the show--
not before we finish.
And we're also going to take
office hours questions.
And Jeffrey will answer those
before you even ask them.
That's what he's good at.
So Jarek, what was the first
talk you want to talk about?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So
we thought about a
good sequence to cover.
And the first one we wanted to
cover is one that recently we
blogged about, about
getting direct
feedback from your community.
So this is a talk that Jeff
and Eric Lundberg did at
Google I/O. So I was thinking
that perhaps Jeff could talk
about it more detail
since he's the
subject domain expert.
And he's really big on getting
feedback from various
communities.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Sure.
I wanted to just do
a brief recap.
The videos are online for all
these talks as Jarek said.
So I don't want to re-give my
Google I/O presentation.
I don't think I have it
memorized by any means, so I
wouldn't be able to
if I wanted to.
But from a very high level,
this Google I/O talk was
basically announcing
two things.
And we actually announced two
things that weren't quite
ready for people to use yet at
Google I/O. But in the week
since then, we've made them
publicly available.
So as of right now, folks can
go out and try both of these
things that I'm talking
about, which is great.
So two aspects of the
announcement.
The first was what we're
calling our--
I guess it's the YouTube
embeddable upload widget.
It's had a couple of different
internal names.
I think that's the one we've
kind of settled on though.
And you can think of this as
something that's very similar
to the YouTube embedded
player.
But instead of allowing you to
embed YouTube playback in your
site, you can embed a way of
capturing YouTube video from
any user's webcam.
And that video then gets
uploaded into that user's
YouTube accounts.
Obviously this is done first
asking the user.
There's consent that
needs to be done.
You have to click some
buttons before
webcam recording starts.
And your user needs
to be logged into
their own YouTube account.
So these videos all go into the
specific end user accounts.
They don't go into one master
YouTube account.
And that's very much in keeping
with our recommended
best practices.
And this is something
we've been hearing
about, I don't know--
I think the original feature
request for this is probably
about four years old.
So we've offered this type of
upload from directly within
YouTube.com.
There's been a page that you
could go to for a while and
record new videos using
your webcam.
There's all sorts of different
types of integration that make
use of being able to put this
on your own page and to
solicit feedback from people
who are viewing your page,
members of your site's
community.
So we're really excited
about the potential
ways of using this.
And in addition to just kind of
the simple way of dropping
in an IFrame on the page that
has the widget, we also have a
nice JavaScript API which is
very similar again to our
YouTube player JavaScript API.
And this lets you do things like
keep track of when the
video has been uploaded and get
back the video ID, which
is useful if you ever want to
curate the videos that have
been submitted.
That's the main integration
point.
There are a few other methods
which we have documented.
JJ BEHRENS: Jeffrey, I
love this feature.
And I'm really, really happy
that we implemented this.
I was really looking forward
to it for a long time.
And I know that you see YouTube
embeds all across the
internet, and we have
an API for embedding
this on your own website.
Do you think we'll start seeing
this widget popping up
in various sites like blogs and
so forth so you can upload
video comments all
across the web?
JEFFREY POSNICK: I'm
certainly hoping.
So video commenting is one of
the areas that we have kind of
envisioned as being
perfect for this.
And during our Google I/O talk,
we showed off a demo of
very initial integration with
a company called Formspring
which is kind of like a
questions and answer website.
And they hacked something
together for us, and we're
grateful that they were
able to do that.
And it shows how you could
post a question and allow
people to post video responses,
answer your
question, which is just
a whole new level of
interactivity which is great.
So they're making good use of
the API, and I think you'll be
able to see that on
your live website
hopefully before too long.
We haven't fully rolled
it out yet.
JJ BEHRENS: That's
pretty awesome.
And you integrated this
into YouTube Direct?
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah.
So the other aspect of the
talk is something that we
announced called YouTube
Direct Lite.
And I think I've talked about
YouTube Direct at pretty much
every opportunity I've
had in the past.
And for those who are not
familiar with it, it's a
platform that's been around for
a while that allows you to
embed a submission widget on a
webpage and that, up until
now, you could submit videos
either via something stored
locally on your hard drive or if
you already had a video in
your YouTube account, you could
say, OK, I want this
video to be considered
a submission for this
particular use case.
One of the common use cases that
we've seen in the past
are news organizations,
for instance.
Like a news organization might
say, hey, submit some videos
related to this tornado that
we just had in this area.
And folks could do
user-generated content and
make folks aware of that.
So that's been around
for a while.
The existing YouTube Direct
platform was written on Java
App Engine.
Kind of required a little bit
of expertise in order to set
up and deploy properly.
And we've been hearing for a
long time that folks want
something that's easier
to deploy, and
a lot lighter weight.
And that's what YouTube
Direct Lite is.
So we were happy to announce
that as well.
You could start using it
today if you'd like.
And the basic use case is as
simple as dropping an IFrame
onto any existing web page.
And that will let you solicit
videos via a number of
different mechanisms.
And one of those mechanisms is
that webcam upload widget.
So this kind of takes care
of the whole curation and
moderation use case in which
the webcam widget itself
doesn't really provide
any method to do.
The YouTube upload webcam
widget is great
for soliciting videos.
But once they've been solicited,
there's no
interface built in for
moderating those submissions
or keep showing what's
been submitted.
So YouTube Direct Lite kind of
fills that void, and lets you
approve any videos that
have been submitted.
And once they get approved, they
get added to a playlist
that is hosted in your
own account.
So it's very easy to feature any
submissions after they've
been approved and say, hey,
these are the great videos
that I've had a chance to
review, and I want to share
with the rest of the world.
So we're looking forward
to folks using that.
Full information is available
on a recent blog post on
apiblog.youtube.com.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, I imagine
adoption is going to be pretty
good considering the
first step is no
longer install Eclipse.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah,
you know what?
Not having to provide support
for people who are not
programmers-- and I personally
don't know my way through
every single aspect
of Eclipse.
And asking somebody who's not a
developer to do that, it's a
pretty big burden.
So I'm really happy that we
could provide something that's
easier to use.
JJ BEHRENS: That's
pretty cool.
So the webcam widget was
definitely a big announcement
at Google I/O, but we also
announced another thing in our
next talk which is called new
YouTube Android Player Tools.
What was that?
The secret thing that
we were trying to
keep secret from everyone.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yes.
So I'm going to have to correct
you because we have
pre-announced it.
JJ BEHRENS: Oh, I'm sorry.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And that was
a session by Ross and Anton
from our mobile engineering
team.
One of the frequent topics that
we discussed previously
during our Hangouts was the
process of embedding YouTube
videos into mobile
applications.
And whenever a question came up
about it, I would typically
wave my hands a lot.
I'd seem quite uncomfortable.
I would sweat a little bit.
And then I would try
to address it.
So with this new API that we
will be launching, these
questions will become a
lot easier to answer.
So the fundamental problem we're
solving is, how do we
reliably embed YouTube
content into native
applications on Android?
So if you're an Android
developer, build an Android
application, and you would
like to incorporate video
playback, but you do not want
to have what's called an
out-of-body experience where
you launch a YouTube app or
you don't want to have to
struggle with web views and
various limitations of web
views, you can actually use an
API that we will be launching
which allows you to easily
incorporate video playback into
your application and have
a fair amount of control
over that playback.
So Anton and Ross go into detail
in this session about
what are the mechanics of
incorporating the API.
And we also had a few very
interesting demos from our
early adopters.
There's a company called Gloto
that presented last week at
this Hangout.
So they really target the
advertising space.
And they were showing how they
can incorporate video playback
into their app that can be
generated for specific
marketing campaigns.
We had a MotorTrend which was
a Google TV application,
something that I haven't
explicitly mentioned.
But if you're a Google TV
developer and, again, you want
to incorporate video playback
in your Google TV app, the
same API addresses that
problem as well.
So now you can actually build
second screen experiences or
beautiful full screen
experiences with YouTube video
playback around your content
on Google TV.
So MotorTrend did a
very nice demo.
And then another company--
and I don't want to kind
of blow the surprise--
but let me just tell
you that this was
really an amazing demo.
Not so much the application,
which is very beautiful, but
what they were able to perform
on stage during the demo.
So I think we came very
close to really
upending the keynote demo.
I think it was quite--
maybe opinions might--
JJ BEHRENS: It's hard
to compete with guys
jumping out of blimps.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: True, but
I think the co-founder of
Skimble did pretty good.
So I really encourage you to
watch this session video.
The slide deck is linked in
the video description.
And then as I mentioned, it's
pre-announced, so we haven't
launched it yet.
We are however actively seeking
trusted testers.
So if you're building an
interesting application, reach
out to us on G+, and we'll see
if we can hook you up and get
some feedback from you just to
make sure that we really cover
all the various use cases before
we launch the API.
So the session was
a lot of fun.
And I really encourage
you to watch it.
JJ BEHRENS: I wasn't an Android
developer until we
came out with this API, and
I had to learn Android as
quickly as I could.
But the thing that amazed me
the most is when I built an
app using this API, I could show
a video and some stuff to
the right of the video, and then
play the video and then
have it go full screen and
bounce back without stopping
playing, without rebuffering.
Just the smoothness of
moving things around.
That's pretty new.
I mean, we couldn't
do that before.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yes, and
another interesting feature--
and we hear that a lot from
content partners that work
with us-- is the API actually
has monetization capability.
So if you have content that is
monetized on YouTube and you
build, say, a fan app or any
type of app around that
content, the ads will show and
you will be getting revenue
from that content.
So this is something that a
lot of content owners are
experiencing rapid
growth in mobile.
And this is something
we covered at
the session as well.
And in order to both enjoy the
ride and get paid, this is a
great solution to that by
incorporating video playback
using that API.
The monetization capability
remains as is.
JJ BEHRENS: I love the way that
you always bring it down
to the bottom line of helping
our viewers increase their
bottom line.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Show
me the money.
JJ BEHRENS: Show me the money.
So the next talk that we had at
I/O was HTML5 at YouTube:
Stories from the Front Line
by Greg Schechter.
And that was a fun talk.
JEFFREY POSNICK: --represent
some of the
content of the talk.
I was not one of
the presenters.
It was Greg Schechter and
Zoltan from our players
engineering team.
But I did attend as an
audience member.
So I could do what I can, but
I would encourage everybody
also just to watch the video
for a more authoritative
account of what happened.
But yeah, Greg and Zoltan were
just talking about some of the
really interesting types of
integrations that YouTube is
doing using various things that
kind of fall into the
HTML5 umbrella.
The obvious thing being HTML5
video playback, but that's
kind of old news
at this point.
We had a talk last year as well
where we announced the
IFrame embed which will make use
of HTML5 video under some
circumstances.
But Greg and Zoltan were going
into some good details about
things like CSS effects that
they're using for some of the
controls for the new player,
things that are a little bit
more advanced than just
video playback.
I think they were going into
how you could overlay text
tracks on top of video elements,
make use of some of
these emerging standards
to have a really
nice compliant player.
And some performance just
measurements as well, showing
the impact of doing different
approaches.
So that's my very brief
summary of their talk.
Hopefully, that's enough to whet
some folks' appetite and
go out and watch the
video yourself.
JJ BEHRENS: I go to the player
team meetings a lot.
And the one thing that amazes
me is how closely we follow
the industry.
So for instance, we wanted
to go full screen
with the HTML5 player.
And Greg's like well, I'm
watching the Firefox guys and
the Chrome guys and it's going
to be launched at such and
such a date.
So it's just like we wait for
the browsers to have support
and we immediately
start using it.
It's kind of pretty amazing how
cutting edge that team is.
No comment.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Well, I was
just going to say that I'm
actually interested to see at
which point we'll be able to
incorporate HTML5 user media
so that the webcam widget
actually works with HTML5.
I think one thing that Jeff
didn't mention is that we
still require Flash
for the widget.
So it'll be nice to be able to
address multiple runtime
environments.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah, and
that's definitely in Eric--
Eric, the engineer who wrote
it-- it's in his plans.
JJ BEHRENS: So the next talk is
a talk that you led, Jarek.
YouTube API plus Cloud
Rendering equals
Happy Mobile Gamers.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yes.
So that talk is more
of a gaming talk.
We did a talk last year about
video playback, video uploads
from console games.
And our guest speaker was Doug
Muir from Activision.
We talked about Call of Duty:
Black Ops integration that we
did with Treyarch, which
is the studio
that built Black Ops.
JJ BEHRENS: And that was cool,
but it seems like you went way
above and beyond this time.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah, we
always try to do more.
And this year, what we wanted to
target is the mobile space.
As you guys all know, mobile
games are really exploding,
and everybody's a
mobile gamer.
In fact, one of the interesting
stats that we
shared at the session is that
I think in 2014, almost half
of the US population
is predicted to be
playing mobile games.
So that the number is actually
growing quite nicely.
And then internationally that
trend is even stronger.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, that trend is
definitely pretty strong in
my household.
I'm always asking my
wife if she'll
watch me do these sessions.
And she's like, I'm sorry, I'd
rather play some mobile games.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So the
question then becomes, how do
we actually upload videos from
these games, because YouTube
gaming community
is very strong.
People share the
gameplay video.
They show off their
achievements, and they share
tricks and tips.
But in the mobile
context, this is
a little more difficult.
So what we decided to do is
really show it at several
different approaches, just to
this problem, starting with
doing the video rendering
and encoding right
there on the device.
Then an approach that we
prototyped and we spoke
previously at Game Developers
Conference which offloads the
entire rendering and encoding
process into the cloud.
We were actually running the
rendering and encoding on top
of Google Compute Engine except
that the session was on
Wednesday and the Compute Engine
launched on Thursday,
so we couldn't--
JJ BEHRENS: Don't say it.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: This
was Compute Engine.
But now, I can say in
public that it was
Compute Engine actually.
I think we have hidden
that pretty well.
And then so that was kind
of the cloud approach.
And then there was another
approach that we work with a
partner on to actually perform
the actual rendering in the
cloud but do the capture right
there on the device by
intercepting OpenGL calls.
So a couple of different
approaches.
The part that I'm most
excited about is we
had a special guest.
And again, just like in the
previous session, we're not
going to blow the surprise, but
let me just say it was a
member of a very famous YouTube
partner who publishes
basketball trick shot videos.
JJ BEHRENS: Dude,
it was perfect.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: It
was quite perfect.
And I really encourage you
to watch his part of the
presentation.
The interesting part that he
covered is if you are a
content owner and you have a
subscriber base, you can
actually leverage that
subscriber base to help propel
your mobile game very
high on the charts.
So their game actually ended up
being number one on the App
Store and Google Play after
they launched it, largely
thanks to a very loyal
following of their
subscribers.
So that kind of scalable,
interesting approach is
traditionally, people invest
in promoting their games by
advertising and stuff
like that.
How about creating some
interesting content and then
using your YouTube audience to
help you promote the game.
And it has worked for them.
Very interesting presentation.
I really encourage
you to watch it.
JJ BEHRENS: Step
one, go viral.
Step three, profit.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Rest is easy.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
But I'm also really excited by
another partner that you had
in that talk.
You had SummitX Games, the
guys who did Tony Hawk 3.
And as soon as I heard about
that, I was telling all my
kids, hey, I'm hanging
out with the guys who
did Tony Hawk 3.
That was pretty awesome.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yes.
They are called Free
Range Games now.
So it's a studio based here
in northern California.
Very creative, amazing games.
And they are sharing their
experience incorporating video
game play captured to SummitX.
And this is something that we're
working on with them.
And then also they shared a
bunch of experiences, kind of
general mobile design
experiences-- how do you
design a mobile game, what are
the things to watch out for.
So kind of lesson learned based
on their experience.
So very interesting
part as well.
JJ BEHRENS: And I hate to keep
pushing you, put this talk was
so awesome.
Can we talk about the
Unity 3D stuff?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yes.
What we decided to do is to take
a game engine and try to
adapt it to include video
uploads capability since it's
a more scalable model than
trying to ask every game
developer to build
their own stuff.
So to that end actually, we
worked with a partner.
Luminary Studios here, a
Bay Area based company.
And they were able to basically
build a module that
plugs into Unity and performs
the video capture and the
encoding using WebM VP8
and Ogg Vorbis.
So open source technologies as
far as the media encoding and
then Unity engine that is
quite popular and quite
scalable for developers
to build mobile games.
So we are still working on kind
of finishing, polishing
that stuff up.
And we're going to look into how
can we make it available
for Unity developers.
And Unity has been a great
sponsor, so I just wanted to
acknowledge them.
They helped us a lot along
the way with the process.
So I think if we could get game
engines to include this
functionality, then I think
mobile gamers will be quite
happy because finally, I'll be
able to share my Dude Perfect
shots and other achievements
that I achieve instead of
working on YouTube,
which I think that
would be pretty awesome.
JJ BEHRENS: I definitely think
in terms of if there was an
award for coolest talk with most
external partners, with
most collaboration with external
people, this talk
would definitely win it.
It was pretty impressive.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Thank you, JJ.
Are you going to
get me coffee?
JJ BEHRENS: Oh yeah.
So the next talk we had
was YouTube Channels
Get With the Program.
And this was by Dror Shimshowitz
and AJ Crane and
they're project managers-- no
sorry, product managers.
I always gets those
two confused.
And I watched this talk
a couple times.
It was actually pretty good.
It was not a super
technical talk.
But since I spend so much time
working with the YouTube API,
I don't actually know much about
the rest of the YouTube
ecosystem such as
how to go viral.
And they talked a lot about how
to produce good content,
how to use content for your
business, how to increase
engagement and so forth.
And there was some taxidermy
and some--
nope--
and a lot of other interesting
things in that talk.
Did you guys get a
chance to see it?
Or you guys were probably
pretty busy
with your own talks.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I watched the
rehearsal, so this is a
secret that I will share.
We do rehearse these talks.
JJ BEHRENS: A couple times.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And it was
quite interesting actually.
I felt like some of the content
was a little similar
to your webinar that you did,
YouTube for Your Business.
But they really focused on all
the different ways in which
you can create interesting
content and how creating
content for YouTube is actually
different than for
kind of traditional media.
One of the interesting aspects
that they stressed--
and I've seen that before as
well-- is to make content not
advertisements.
So a lot of the YouTube
content-- and you gave an
example of that.
It was actually quite
fun to watch.
So you may not even know that
you're watching an ad, but it
actually is an ad.
It's just a YouTube way of
doing it which has proven
very, very entertaining
and quite successful.
So one thing that I think that
talk really helps people
with-- and it kind
of ties back into
what we talked earlier--
is if you have a business and
you're an entrepreneur,
YouTube is a great way to
promote your product.
And then if you get subscribers,
they give you
tips about how you actually
build a subscriber base with
your content.
Once you have them, they can
actually help you be
successful with your product.
So I know all of us here are
developers, but a lot of
people that we interact with
are entrepreneurs and they
write code and they also have to
figure out a way to pay the
bills and be successful.
So I think considering YouTube
to promote the
product, it's a good idea.
But then again, I'm biased.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, well.
The one thing I've noticed
being at YouTube for long
enough is that the PMs
are always the ones
with the best videos.
I went to that talk.
It's not technical.
But my goodness, all those
videos were hilarious.
And it was like instant
memes, instantly
forwarding those to my wife.
I mean they're ads, but
they're so good.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: They're
fun, for sure.
JJ BEHRENS: Good stuff.
So the next one was Mobile
YouTube API Apps for Content
Creators, Curators,
and Consumers.
And this was another magic trick
that you pulled together
with 10 billion external
partners.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
So actually we had a three
partners co-presenting.
And also our product manager
in charge of mobile product
offering, Andrey Doronichev,
flew in from London for this
presentation.
So what we were trying to do is
really help showcase APIs
that enable content creation,
curation, and consumption on
YouTube in the mobile context.
We talked about the history and
the trends that we see on
YouTube with mobile consumption
and creation.
Andrey also discussed in some
detail the latest version of
our YouTube mobile app with
some really exciting
capabilities, just to kind
of show where we're
going with the app.
And then we had demos
from WeVideo.
And that company builds really
nice creation experiences,
both traditional HTML-based web
approach as well as mobile.
We had 955 Dreams.
And they built Band of the Day,
History of Jazz, On the
Way to Woodstock.
So a lot of very
beautiful apps.
When I talked to them, they
mentioned that the category
that they're trying to pursue is
coffee table applications.
So they're just so pretty that
you can toss away your coffee
table book and just put the
tablet with the app on your
coffee table.
And they talked about how
do you build beautiful
consumption experience.
And then finally, last but not
least, some of you that have
been following some of the
integrations we've been
working on recently,
we did launch an
integration with Flipboard.
So if you're a Flipboard fan,
they have been on iOS for
quite some time.
Recently they launched an
Android app integrated with G+
as well as YouTube.
So now we can subscribe.
You can follow your
favorite YouTube
content creators on Flipboard.
You could also interact.
So you can like videos, you
can comment on videos all
within Flipboard app.
So they consumed a bunch of our
standard feeds, and they
integrated the interactivity
into the app as well.
So they talked about their
experience with the API and
did a very nice demo on the
tablet and the mobile device.
So that was a lot of fun.
Like you said, quite
a few partners.
That's always tricky to
get it all together.
But I think it's an interesting
session.
If you're building mobile
applications and you're
looking for some hints about how
to include video and some
best practices, really I think
that that session will be
valuable because the quality
of the apps that were
showcased during the session
was quite high.
JJ BEHRENS: One thing that I
really liked about this talk
is that you would say, here's
what I'm talking about, either
curation, creation,
or so forth.
And then here's an API
and how to do it.
And then here's this beautiful
app that spent half of its
time being app of the week
at the Apple App Store.
It was just such a compelling
experience.
And those apps were
just beautiful.
I'm never going to code anything
as beautiful as that.
Those are just amazing.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Keep
trying though, JJ.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, pretty cool.
And then finally, we had a
Codelab that Jeffrey led
called Master the Latest
YouTube Data API.
Tell us about the latest
APIs, the ones
fresh off the presses.
JEFFREY POSNICK: I think the
APIs are still kind of on the
presses being further pressed,
because we do not have
anything publicly ready
for folks to try yet.
And I know that's been a source
of frustration for a
lot of people out there.
So apologies in advance before
I go into talking about how
cool these things are.
So yeah, we had a Codelab.
And this Codelab was an
introduction to both the new
version of the YouTube Data API,
which we are calling v3.
Not the most inspired name,
but technically accurate.
It is our third major revision
of the data API.
And this is the first version
that is no longer based on the
older legacy GData format.
So GData had a bunch of Atom XML
streams and a whole set of
infrastructure built
up around this.
But in the past couple years in
particular, you might have
noticed that Google has been
migrating to a different type
of back-end infrastructure for
all of our newer APIs.
And that's the same
infrastructure that the new
data API is built on.
So there's a number
of very visible
changes because of that.
But there's a number of
very real benefits for
developers out there.
Being on this new back-end API
infrastructure means that we
have a very rich set of client
libraries that are being
maintained actively by teams
within Google that can be used
with this new set of
APIs and has native
support for OAuth 2.
As I'm sure everyone is aware,
we are strongly encouraging
everybody to use OAuth 2 with
our even older legacy APIs.
With the new API, you
have to use OAuth 2.
There is no more client login,
there's no more AuthSub.
This is a good thing.
If you're not sure why, there's
a lot of time you
could spend talking about OAuth
2 and there's a lot of
good resources out there
for learning
as to why it's important.
So that's going to be a really
big change for developers--
getting started with having to
basically rewrite a lot of
existing code.
And we're kind of taking
it a little bit slow
with the data API.
We gave a preview release at
Google I/O to a very limited
set of people.
Basically, the only folks who
are currently white listed to
use the new API are folks that
were in the Codelab that have
had a chance to sit with us and
more or less one on one
learn how to use it.
Not that it's super difficult or
anything like that, but we
really do want to have a very
small set of developers while
we're iterating, internally
changing some things around.
And as soon as we're ready to
publicly release that, we're
going to remove the white list
and everybody's going to be
able to use that.
So that was one of the questions
I saw on our Google
Moderator Thread-- somebody
asking about when they could
use that, these new APIs.
So this is Google, we don't
really give specific ETAs or
anything like that.
The answer is sooner rather
than later though.
We're not anticipating many,
many months to pass before
this is available, let's say.
So the actual substance
of the API--
that was a long-winded way of
describing the background.
But what we rolled out as part
of the Codelab and what we had
people test was some of the new
features of the Data API.
And more interestingly in terms
of new stuff is a brand
new Analytics API.
JJ BEHRENS: It's pretty
cool stuff.
JEFFREY POSNICK: So the docs
for both Data API and
Analytics API are now live on
developers.google.com/youtube.
This is kind of taunting folks
who know you can't quite use
it yet, but you could read
the docs for it.
So you could see what
it will offer.
And it's a really, really
rich analytics reporting
experience.
I'm told that it's very much
modeled on the Google
Analytics API.
So if you've done Google
Analytics stuff before, the
YouTube Analytics API will
apparently be very natural.
And it gives you a lot more
control than what you could do
right now using our existing
Insight API, which is what the
older version of the YouTube
Data API offered.
Insight API was just really the
ability to download a zip
archive that had a bunch
of CSV files.
And while you could write codes
to parse zips and parse
CSVs and format all your data
around, I don't think anybody
really looks forward to writing
that kind of code.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I think
they do, Jeff.
JEFFREY POSNICK: No judging.
Fair enough.
So using the YouTube Analytics
API, it's a real RESTful API.
You just set some report
definitions in your HTTP
request and you'll get back
either some JSON data directly
in your HTTP response, or if you
do want your CSV data, you
could that get that too.
There are lots of interesting
notes to properly formatting
your requests--
the types of ports
that are offered.
The Analytics API is also
not fully complete yet.
The engineering team is actively
adding new features.
So this kind of falls in the
same bucket as the Data API in
terms of not being able
to use it right now.
But sooner rather than later,
you should be able to.
JJ BEHRENS: I know that a lot of
partners have talked to us,
really interested about this
new Analytics API.
And I think it's going to open
up a large number of ways
where we could study why my
videos are not popular.
But I'm also really excited
about this v3 thing, because
traditionally, our client
libraries haven't always been
completely up to date.
And when we move to v3, we're
going to have really, really
good client libraries that are
not just going to work for
YouTube API, but a bunch
of Google APIs.
I think that that's
really cool.
And it also helps me with
my ultimate goal.
If I could port one of those
libraries to Haskell, then I
could rule the world.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: In fact, which
ones were you using at
the Codelab, Jeff?
JEFFREY POSNICK: So the Codelab,
we focused on Python
and JavaScript.
And we actually have, as part
of the public Analytics API
docs, more or less an
adapted version of
the JavaScript Codelab.
So you could see
that publicly.
We're probably going to also
repackage it and turn it into
a Google Developers Academy
course once
it is actually available.
So yeah, we're kind of in an
interesting mode right now.
We're going to have some cool
things launching, and we want
to make sure there's as much
good sample code out there for
developers as possible because
you are going to have to do
some rewrites if you
have some existing
legacy YouTube API code.
So we want to make that as easy
as possible for everyone.
JJ BEHRENS: Well, Google I/O
was a big hit this year.
I mean, it was like
big attendance.
But more than that, we had
a lot of YouTube talks.
I don't think we had that
many last year.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah,
I think that was
our record to date.
So I think if that trend
continues, I think by 2015,
Google I/O will be about
YouTube entirely.
That will be the only topic
that we'll cover.
JJ BEHRENS: We'll have to tell
the Android guys about that.
It's pretty awesome though.
I'm excited about that.
And so of course, you don't have
to just listen to us talk
about those talks.
You could watch those
talks now.
And I encourage you to do so
if you want to learn more
about any of these
specific topics.
Why don't we answer some
questions now?
What do we got going on in
the moderation queue?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Think
there's one question.
I think Jeff referred
to that one already.
It was about YouTube API
Analytics access.
So this is a v3 question.
JEFFREY POSNICK: So again, there
are links that anybody
could go to, to fill out a form
and attempt to apply for
access to these APIs.
It's a little unfortunate that
we can't, as part of that
signup process, give you more
feedback as to if or when
you're going to be approved.
Basically the only folks who
have really been approved
right now are the folks who've
been part of the Codelab.
And as soon as we have
something that
is a lot more stable--
I don't think we're really at
the point where you really can
build anything that is not going
to break one week later
when the next push happens.
So it's not like you're
missing out too much.
And we're going to open up to as
many people as we can once
we have something stable that
we could do that with.
JJ BEHRENS: So after Google
I/O happened, a lot of
Googlers, developer advocates,
and developer programs
engineers, tend to just
collapse because
it's kind of busy.
But Jarek had another idea.
And he decided that he and I
should fly across the world to
London and give a YouTube player
API, Google TV, Mobile
Something Hack-a-Thon.
You want to talk about that?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yes, that
was a final push actually.
When I was little younger,
I used to run marathons.
And this is pretty much
how you do it.
You work really hard and then
you work even harder on the
last couple of miles.
So yes, we did have an
interesting event in London.
There was a weekend event on
a London campus, which is a
really great venue and
an awesome resource.
If you are UK-based, then
I really encourage
you to check it out.
Just a wonderful community
building around it.
The person that runs it,
[INAUDIBLE], is really an
interesting character, very
committed and passionate about
entrepreneurs in general.
So it's a great resource.
So we thought about
trying it out.
And we invited a
bunch of folks.
We had about 18 applications
built by Sunday night.
So really nice set
of applications.
Quite high quality apps.
And we were quite amazed how
quickly people were able to
build interesting applications
with Android Player API.
And there were different
categories.
I think we had five winners.
We had some prizes, and all
the free pizza I can eat.
JJ BEHRENS: And beer.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So I
think it was quite
a successful event.
We hopefully will
do more of that.
And we got some really
good feedback.
Some of the interesting
applications that I thought
were fun were kind of second
screen applications.
So Mobile Plus, Google TV
Tablet, and Google TV.
We had one interesting company
that was basically a
co-founder came to the Friday
night kickoff session with an
idea about building interesting
experience around
the content that they're
going to be producing.
So not the developer, but rather
a content owner or
somebody who wants to
start a network.
And was able to attract a couple
of developers to work
on the idea.
And by Sunday night, they had a
working demo of interesting
mobile experience and TV
experience around the content
that they'll be producing.
So really kind of helps with
the point that if you're
building content and you want
to have some additional
value-add or referrals to your
own content, the type of
experience you want, you could
still do that by syndicating
to YouTube, but then building
out the experience the way you
want it, not the way we want
people to consume media
content, because there's many
ways to skin the cat.
And then because of the
value-add that people include
additional content like
[INAUDIBLE] or whatnot in
their overall experience, it was
kind of a great story, so
we really liked that.
So lots of interesting ideas.
JJ BEHRENS: That was
a beautiful demo.
But my favorite was when they
had one of the contestants
entered an app where it's
playing a playlist on a Google
TV, and then people could gather
around the TV with
their Android phones--
and let me pull one out.
And if you don't like the video,
you point your phone
kind of at the TV and
you tilt it up.
And it's like reading
the accelerometer to
figure out your tilt.
And if you don't like it, you
pull back like a slingshot and
then let go.
And it flings a virtual tomato
at the screen and it explodes
on the screen.
And if enough tomatoes hit the
video, then the video gets
taken down, and the next one
played in the playlist.
That was pretty amazing.
There's Android here, there's
Google TV, there's like
accelerometer type
stuff, there's
second screen type stuff.
That was a pretty
amazing demo.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: It
was really fun.
And one thing that I wanted to
mention is we were quite lucky
we were able to get quite a few
Googlers to the event and
sit there with the developers
for the whole weekend.
So that was one of the teams
that had attracted quite a few
Googlers helping out.
Really awesome demo.
JJ BEHRENS: Any other apps that
you can remember that you
particularly liked?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: One that was
interesting and won an
honorable mention was an app
that basically teaches you how
to do various things
on your phone.
So this is kind of the missing
manual problem.
And what they would do is record
videos about various
phone functions and then build
an app around that experience.
So it's kind of help, but it's
video help for your phone that
comes with your phone.
So they came up with the idea
and they pitched it.
They were able to build a
prototype at that event.
And they'll be moving
forward with it.
So that was a cool
little project.
JJ BEHRENS: That was
pretty cool.
It amazed me just how many
people were doing second
screen type stuff
with Google TV.
I think that second screen is
going to be a hot topic.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So which
one is second,
the TV or the mobile?
JJ BEHRENS: For me, I think
that might be a personal
preference.
So anything else?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I thought
maybe it might make sense for
Jeff to talk a little bit
about some of the API
additions that we
made recently.
I know he's been busy posting
to news groups and
anticipating people's questions
about them as he
always does.
So Jeff, what do you think?
Any updates on the recent
launches that people
should be aware of?
JEFFREY POSNICK: Sure.
There are a couple of recent
changes, one of which is
captured in a blog post that
went up yesterday talking
about the new
getVideoLoadedFraction method
that is now part of
the Player API.
And this is something that
supersedes and more or less
deprecates two other methods
that had existed for a while
called getVideoBytesLoaded
and getVideoBytesTotal.
Pretty much what we saw was that
the way people would use
getVideoBytesLoaded and
getVideoBytesTotal was just by
doing a division, by getting the
total number of bytes in
the video and dividing that into
the number of bytes that
are loaded to try to figure out
how much of a video has
already been offered.
And then they were using that
information to display a
buffer bar in their own custom
playback experience.
So we kind of removed the need
to do that division by having
one method that will return
that fraction for you
automatically.
So if you had 50% of the video
that's already been buffered,
getVideoLoadedFraction will
return 0.5 of it, and you
could use that directly from
in your application.
This is also nice because there
are some scenarios such
as when HTML5 video playback
is being used where we were
never able to actually return
an accurate count of the
number of bytes that were
available just to [INAUDIBLE]
HTML5 video element worked.
So we always had to kind of
return this approximation that
didn't really make sense
as a byte count anyway.
So we're kind of doing away with
the pretension that these
things are bytes that
were returning.
We're just giving you
a fraction that
you could use yourself.
So we have a standard
deprecation policy.
And the getVideoBytesLoaded and
getVideoBytesTotal method
are not going away today
or anything like that.
But do consider them officially
deprecated.
Try moving on to
getVideoLoadedFraction instead.
JJ BEHRENS: That's great.
JEFFREY POSNICK:
We also have--
something we would not blog
about, but it's just come up
at least in forum once or twice,
and I know that Jarek's
been getting some questions
about it too, which is one of
our standard views that
we'd make available as
part of the Data API.
And this is a feed of videos
that we refer to as
most_viewed.
So that's most underscore
viewed.
For a while now, we haven't
really been populating that
with anything meaningful.
There are a number of reasons
why that's been the case.
JJ BEHRENS: Is that because like
the Tommy Bit My Finger
just can never be replaced in
terms of number of views?
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yes.
I'm going to go with
JJ's explanation.
The basic thrust of this though
is that most_viewed is
not going to be updated
moving forward.
And we're recommending that
folks no longer use that.
If you're looking for a feed
of videos to use that will,
for instance, highlight things
that are really popular on
YouTube, the aptly named most
underscore popular video feed
is a great feed to use
for that purpose.
That's going to continue
to be updated.
And it's a great way to pull
in interesting content into
your application if you want to
surface whatever's trending
on YouTube right now.
So we recommend folks
to use that instead.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
JJ BEHRENS: Well, that
was a great session.
Thank you very much Jeffrey
and great set
of Google I/O talks.
Thanks for joining us here.
And we will see-- it seems like
we're going to move to
every week now.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: We're going
to do every week and then I
think Jeff wants to do
every day, but we're
pushing back right now.
I'm not sure we're
ready for that.
JJ BEHRENS: Dammit, and
we're doing it live.
We'll do it live.
OK, thanks a lot guys.
Take care.
JEFFREY POSNICK:
Bye everybody.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]